[Music]
what would you like I want to try
everything do you maybe want to try not
opening with 1 minute and 45 seconds of
previously ons and logos huh do you do
you maybe want to try that because when
you do it this
way I'm sinning it thoughts well
confusion firstly because last we saw
the Lok had been convenienc at high
speed into Mobius and now out of nowhere
we're in txas in London in the 70s and I
only enjoy one of those three things
also in case you confused it with London
Asgard it's too safe it's not a war zone
it's not an apocalypse tell me you know
nothing about 1970s London without
actually telling me you know nothing
about 1970s London we got a hit on a
temp pad that belonged to Hunter X5
before it went dark his information
Mobius is apparently only sharing with
Loki now this means that Loki was told
to wear a tux and walk walked through
this time door and presumably did so
without a single clarifying question
yeah that totally seems on brand oh the
Bridget B rumors TR o Ron Ron you cannot
ask me about that not realizing that
asking the questions you're not supposed
to ask is the mo of every tabloid
journalist ever also tabloid journalism
will there be a zaniac 2 speculating
about a sequel before the initial movie
has even left the theater everyone on
the internet stop it sequel for the fans
for the fans probably not for bucket
loads of profit based on name
recognition most definitely oh my God
it's Brad wolf can I get your autograph
anything for a sure is Handy that mobus
and Loki decided to travel separately
from B15 and that she decided to wait in
this alley for X5 surprise appearances
that don't make sense or
fun hold it look he does still have
powers and stuff right why is he letting
Mobius do all the literal leg work
instead of god of Mischief a trap for
damn it Loki that is so not what I'm me
and you know it also I'm not the suit
jacket being unbuttoned in this scene
you still glad we're here I mean not
really I actually wanted a season two
for moonnight they had a lady hippo God
people is Loki really giving Chase on
foot what is he doing getting his steps
in playing with his food times of the
essence here so why isn't he just
surrounding Brad with 20 naked lokis
what don't act like that wouldn't stop
you too also does Brad really think he's
going to outrun a God I mean he kind of
does for a while but he shouldn't have
assumed that waiting until you're
cornered to teleport away and even then
only teleporting a few blocks instead of
changing cities countries planets
timelines or TV shows what is this
that's a temp pad I'm pretty certain the
writers didn't anticipate me associating
the term temp pad with some sort of
emergency short-term feminine hygiene
product but here we are and you're
welcome but he will talk once he's had
time to marinate making me marinate on
the idea that I thought I'd been
marinating my meat when I've actually
been marinating it with a marinade so
that it can marinate and the knowledge
that I'm not going to remember any of
that that the next time I use either of
these words what about this have OB
check it out suddenly OB is everyone's
first option for troubleshooting so why
wasn't this the case last season where
the was he you've been robbing us of KIU
Quan as if he hadn't been cast yet
everything you need to know about this I
wrote about it in here okay but that's
the manual for the OG temp ad right how
is that manual going to help with a
modified dad R Slayer killed C20
attempted to kill Mobius threw me in
time jail and tried to take over the TVA
previously on last time obviously lazy
Recaps position Casey tell them what you
just told me putting aside the fact that
I don't remember who Casey even is why
didn't B15 just relay his message it's
not like he says anything complicated or
did you just want to make sure he'd be
here to say something important about
the temp pad X5 says it somehow blocks
TVA tracking that's not what it does as
I suspected thank the writers for making
sure Tad nerd was here to help but I
have to wonder how much time Loki and
mobus would have wasted fiddling with
this thing before asking for help did
they really think OB was the only temp
pad whiz at the TVA thank you wait why
is Loki taking the temp pad why isn't he
leaving it with liveaction Rutherford to
work on it this holding cell is huge you
can feel like 50 people in here and I
hate that I think that's actually normal
for a prison it's you you're the problem
it's him hi he's the problem low key
stop trying to be a hero man is The God
Who successfully manipulated almost
every member of The Avengers actually
getting pissy about some guy named Brad
is that what I'm watching right
now it's really good mobus and Loki have
key time lime pie for this wait tried to
use the mindstone on Tony star it didn't
work so I threw him off the building
sometimes our emotions get the better of
us comparing slapping a man who's
insulting you to throwing a man off a
building for trying to prevent you from
subjugating an entire planet
X5 you know obviously tou a nerve right
continuing to call someone by a name
they hate sure he may have picked Brad
but it's still his choice well come on
you're the god of Mischief yeah but he's
also the god of changing into a horse
and getting knocked up by a stallion but
nobody ever talks about that bit we're
definitely getting desperate and I'll be
honest with you we're down to our last
option wait does that mean you only had
three options to begin with because so
far we've seen two attempts Mobius
asking nicely and Loki asking as
threateningly as an English accent will
allow how are we now with the last
option need I say it again ly has magic
powers so guess what I wrote a little
script of my own thing Edward Norton
said while filming The Incredible Hulk
somehow makes it into the episode oh
well good on Marvel for not letting
anything go to waste Mobius get in here
why don't you just let him in yourself
Brad there's nothing stopping you from
opening the door and calling Loki's
Bluff false tension attempt is dumb why
is this scarier than anything Loki could
summon with his mind Powers isn't the
beauty of his abilities that he could
put Brad through any number of hideous
scenarios without physically hurting him
I may need to reassess my definition of
the word beauty just tell me where
Sylvie is making Loki the protagonist of
your TV show has always been strange
given his problematic past but I'm glad
we're finally addressing that by
watching him torture a man why you so
hard on yourself BR that's actually not
his fault the script needed him to make
it hard so we could temp ad the run time
to 40 minutes see little bit of mief i
as good as your plan Mobius comes in and
immediately gives away that he was in on
Loki's plan all along which lets Brad
know he wasn't in any real danger
however Brad ignores this and and just
continues to cooperate as if they hadn't
just undermined their advantage for no
reason you're or a Bor did Hunter B15
not explain who she was taking you to on
the way down here that's either a sin
for her for not explaining or a sin on
you for not paying attention and since I
have no idea which I'll just have to
send both possibilities and risk
creating a branch in the sacred sin line
will you sign mine for me of course I
will happy to do it yeah just next to
your picture next to his picture but we
just saw him say you're or aor as if he
had no idea who he was looking at was
the picture taken from behind so we have
to convince a rogue artificial
intelligence to come back to work Casey
would be predictive at43 sins it took me
about 4 seconds of research to discover
that Marvel actually worked with
McDonald's to recreate this 1980s Era
restaurant so instead of trying to fish
out any nitpicky inconsistencies here's
a in for McDonald's bankrolling a God
that tried to murder a bunch of people
in 2012 does no one remember that time
he ripped an eyeball out of an innocent
man's head even blurred I can see that
this fountain soda machine has three
options for sprite which is fing
disgusting those buttons should be
filled with high sea Fanta and Diet Coke
protocol dictates I assign one sin for
each Sprite nozzle show makes me realize
that this would have been the perfect
fing time to bust out that Taylor Swift
anti-hero gag instead of blowing it on
Brad's setup earlier damn it Brad my
break's in 5 minutes wow good thing Loki
and Mobius teleported there exactly 5
minutes before sylv's break can you
imagine how awkward it would have been
if they' arrived after she'd had her
break or wasn't working at all so you
see the future now cool when you've
literally been to the end of time itself
you don't get to be skeptical about
something as minute as seeing the future
that should be like the most normal
thing Loi has done up to this point you
like it here you like this place that's
McDonald's IST I mean fair but still and
now here we are enjoying a meal like
gentlemen well you're enjoying a meal
but Brad only has a shake for both of
you to be enjoying a meal he technically
needs to have food as well you could at
least buy the guy some fries or nuggies
it's not scary it's elevated Thriller
all right the phrase elevated Thriller
you just going to give everyone Free
Will and walk away well it's better than
taking their swimming pool ladder away
and then giving them free will rest in
peace my Sims rest in peace they're
going to bomb every Branch yeah
including this one for a second there I
was so immersed in the world that I
assumed doc was declaring war
specifically on McDonald's and
destroying them one branch at a time and
the fact that I didn't immediately
question that means some sort of shark
has jumped one too many product
placements do wasn't looking for Sylvie
she's going to prune all the new
branches she already is so to recap the
information that M and Loki went through
all of that trouble to discover his
information that would have been
revealed had they just stayed at the TVA
and waited excellent glad I was here for
the ride 10 out of 10 they've Prov 30%
of the branches show wants me to
allocate my precious give a to 30% of
something it hasn't bothered to show me
that's how they're bombing all the
timelines at once they're all connected
to that central control panel she said
with the confidence of someone who's
examined the setup for much longer than
the 3 seconds she's been here also they
aren't bombing them all at once right
this graphic shows that they're
gradually being picked off in succession
if the point point of the machine is to
destroy all the branches simultaneously
then which quit jumped the gun and blew
up a branch that triggered the TVA you
should waited till all the bombs were
planted in then you're golden I should
not be better at destroying universes
than docs I'll okay now that the fate of
billions of lives are at stake I'm sure
Loki will start using his powers instead
of in the name of the all father damn it
Loki you're not Captain America this is
not why we love Lok don't overthink it
overthink what the fact that this
Machinery go go bye-bye dusting should
have been the power move you opened with
Mobius you should come back you better
come back and take a look at this
cliche portals that know exactly how
long to stay open depending on the drama
of the moment I'm going home if it's
still there should your timad tell you
if it's still there when you try to
connect to your home like is there a
chance she just walks into [__]
Oblivion oh that's the thing that I
totally remember that does the thing
that I should be excited to buy yes it
was in the previous Leon but you didn't
tell me what it was or where it came
from damn it episode does not contain a
goooo and bothur
ra we should look for him in the ball
pit at McDonald's little over the top
don't you think all the shadow
play I'm Azie Osborne and I'm the Prince
of Darkness do you have any idea what
kind of life you might have left behind
why didn't you just go home that's your
home are you too good for your home kiwi
kiwi
you said it was a key lime pie no I
didn't I said kiwi lime that's what
makes it so special that's what's going
to kill me I wrote a little script of my
own it's called get up you're or a
Boris yes I love how you program sub
routines it's breathtaking I feel so
good to say it you know what they call a
quarter pound of a cheese in par they
don't call her a quarter pounder with oh
man they got the metric system they
would know what the a quarter pounder is
enjoying a meal like gentlemen nothing
beats two cheeseburgers with secret
sauce